knock up by Zach Miller talking about
the importance of NLP importance of
pipelines in NLP okay can you guys hear
me yes no okay
hey so yeah like you said my name's Zach
and I'm gonna be talking about the
importance of pipelines in NLP and how
we should think about them and if I'm
being honest the previous talk stole
like half of my thunder so we're gonna
see how this gets so this is the the
title that I gave so that I would get
into the conference this is the title
that I wish I could have given to get
into the conference
I love / hate NLP and it should suck
less so let's talk I think it's
important to kind of set who I am and to
give you sort of expectations for this
talk one I'm a physicist that kind of
went rogue I basically got sick of
academia and was like I can't do this
anymore and that means that I came into
computer science and data science with
no computer science background like none
so a lot of the things I'm going to talk
about are things that I learned while I
was realizing that computer science
doesn't have to be the worst experience
of my life but I am uncomfortably into
numerical optimization and talking about
gradient descent so I also don't have an
NLP background like language is not my
forte so like whatever the opposite of
the grammar police is that's me like you
could barely speak English to me and I'd
like that's great it's fine I don't care
so when I start doing NLP like I'm not
coming at this looking for technical
reports or anything and so the last
thing that I think is important is that
I'm a person who loves repeatable
processes I want to be able to come in
and say I give you this data I get this
thing out and that is the opposite of
NLP as well so realistically what I am
is a non NLP expert who does natural
language processing sometimes but really
hates the process of doing natural
language processing like I love it it's
my least favorite thing about being a
data scientist so that's where I'm
coming from and so the problems that I
see with NLP basically come down to this
machine learning is what I want to do
and it only likes numbers words aren't
numbers and the process for turning
words into numbers is much more art than
science so when I start making choices
at the
of my pipeline what happens downstream
is not apparent I can't just say well I
tweaked this and therefore this is going
to happen so it's basically what we're
gonna be digging into today is how do I
make that suck less
so since I'm going after an NLP talk
this is going to be kind of redundant
but we're gonna do it anyway because I
budgeted for 25 minutes and we're gonna
do this so I'm gonna give you sort of a
high-level in LP like view of what we're
going to do for machine learning so
we're gonna start with some document and
then we basically have the feature
extraction steps that Justin was just
talking about so we're gonna have some
tokenizer something that says you know
what this we can't treat this as a big
block of text I need to look at this at
a word level or some subsection level so
that's what my tokenizer is gonna do I'm
then gonna throw it into some sort of
cleaner that says okay this type of word
can't handle this I can't handle
punctuation I need to do this this and
this to make my text useful and then
finally I might throw it into some
stimming or limit izing or something
along those lines so meaning well we'll
just get to that in a second so
basically this functions as my data
preparation or my feature extraction
part and this part is basically the the
be-all end-all like this if I do this
wrong nothing else matters and so
there's gonna be a lot of work on this
side and in particular there's a lot of
work because there's a lot of ways you
can do this so let's start with this
sentence I'm from Chicago I've spent the
last several years hating and loving
natural language processing so if I
start with this and I throw it into a
tokenizer let's just start with a simple
one where I break on spaces okay so now
all of these words become individual
pieces that I can build upon but there's
not just one way to tokenize right so I
could then say well all of these these
contractions are something that I don't
want to deal with so a different
tokenizer might say cool let's break
those apart I'm gonna have some lookup
dictionary I'm gonna break those apart
and I'm gonna go from I'm to I am and
I've - I have and so now I have two
choices of tokenizer right so I've got
one here with where I don't do this one
where I do this there's 30 other choices
that I could make let's stick with two
for now okay now for cleaning I can go
from capital I and like lowercase
everything
and that becomes my my choice for
cleaning but there's another choice I
could make where I remove punctuation
there's a choice that could make where I
don't remove punctuation there's a ton
of ways you can go with that for
stimming I could choose to convert like
the M and have into B and has so that
are more consistent because consistency
across my data if I want to understand
the words is going to be very very
important it's that's reducing noise
step of trying to make my pipeline work
and I can take things like process from
processing and all of those those steps
there's just so many choices that you
can make stemmer to might say you know
what instead of hating and loving I'll
say hate and love so this again like I
just want to impress upon you there's
tons of choices being made and I'm only
three steps into my pipeline so I
haven't even really gotten to a point
yet where I can decide is it working or
not and I've already made like 20
choices so the next step would be let's
go from my my data prep to converting to
numeric so to do that I'm going to do a
couple more steps which is remove some
stop words I'm going to do some named
entity recognition and then I'm going to
do some vectorization so these guys
again are it's not an exhaustive but
this is kind of like the steps that I
might take and what that does then is I
can go from this sentence and take out
all of the words that are common that
aren't giving me a lot of information so
I be from and I have that's junk
essentially right that's noise the word
and conveys nothing to me so maybe I
take those out and I end up with this
sentence Chicago spent past several
years hate love natural language
processing now depending on my cleaner
I may have process or I may have
processing I may have different
punctuation I may have different words
split out there's tons of variables here
I could also get even more fancy and say
you know what my stop words maybe I need
some domain-specific soft stop words so
I'm going to take those out as well
there's another some more choices for
named entity recognition I can do things
like removing Chicago and replacing it
with generic City so that I know that in
my pipeline I don't necessarily care
that it's Chicago or New York or
whatever it's just city name
and so that's one choice I could make
for a named entity recognition or maybe
I do something where I'd make another
choice which is take New York and make
it new underscore York so that I
understand that I'm talking about the
block of New York not the words new and
New York so again more choices and then
finally for vectorization maybe I just
count the words or maybe I normalize it
and scale it it's more choices okay so
I've said choices a lot so let's let's
move on so after I've done all of this
after I've got my data to numbers that's
when I can start making choices about
the actual modeling in the machine
learning so up until here I haven't even
done anything let's call it useful yeah
I haven't said you know what I need have
an end goal of making this prediction
nothing has happened yet that leads me
to that all I've done is said my data is
terrible how do I make it less terrible
and that's the entire like first six
steps okay so if we we draw this out and
a somewhat suggestive format we can look
and say you know what let's just let's
keep it simple we'll say let's look
through like three tokenizer is two
cleaners three steamers four different
sets of stop words two different sets of
named entities and two vectorizer
methods this is not particularly
exhaustive this is just like hey I might
find these like you could find all of
this since I can't learn just this many
examples kind of thing so because I've
drawn it suggestively you may already be
putting these lines in but if I draw
these lines there's now 36 unique
combinations of ways that I could
explore my data before I even get to any
modeling choices right this is just
pre-processing and so if I look at this
and I say you know what I want to know
what what the best choices to be made
are that's not clear because a this is a
very interconnected system and B each
choice has really big downstream effects
so if I say go to this tokenizer and I
say you know what I'm just gonna hold
everything else constant and switch this
tokenizer and see what the result is
that's not going to tell me anything
because the choice of tokenizer here may
change how my named entity recognizer
works so this highly interconnected
system is now a problem for me that I
need to try to solve and so basically at
this point I've complained a lot about
NLP
that's that's what we've accomplished so
far so let me talk about some possible
solutions so the the I guess the most
naive or simplistic solution is to
basically take this is my rifle Creed
and apply it to your NLP pipeline and
say I will only ever use these pieces
and I'm going to learn these pieces
inside and out until I can no longer
learn anything new about them so for
instance I might choose this tokenizer
and this cleaner and this Zimmer and
what I can do then is really focus in
and say I know exactly how to changes in
this tokenizer are going to change the
behavior of my stop words or my my limit
Iser so as I study those interconnected
pieces I can really get a sense of like
how to use my pipeline for what I want
it to do but the the sort of the the
downside to that is something that we're
also going to have to confront here
shortly
now I'm showing you this as why not just
do this which means that I'm leading you
to the conclusion that you probably
shouldn't but I will say that most
people do so like this is not a bad
solution by any stretch of the
imagination and I know that because
that's what all of these do right and
they're way smarter than I am so like
I'm not saying they're wrong I'm not
saying it's a bad approach I'm saying we
may want to consider some other
approaches because pipelines shouldn't
be inflexible right so like when you
look at these guys like text blob just
takes a bunch of stuff from NLT Kay and
says these are the these are what I'm
choosing this is the thing you give me
your text I give you the thing back out
Spacey does the same thing but it does
it in a way faster and more enterprise
away jinsim does something similar and
Stanford's group does something similar
but in Java so it's also faster so they
basically have said you know what
there's too many choices we're just
gonna make one pipeline that works
pretty well across everything and we're
gonna make it super fast and that's
really not a bad choice but there are
other approaches and that's what we're
gonna talk about now okay so the reason
that that could be a bad choice is
basically comes down to this right the
Fellowship of the Ring is not equivalent
to a chicken Caesar salad sounds so good
right now
okay so if I'm applying my pipeline to
say token I can't expect that same
pipeline is going to work just as well
on Twitter data because Twitter data is
inherently incomprehensible like you
can't just say you know what I'm going
to to throw out certain words because
they're common in Tolkien's and and then
apply that over here on Twitter right
because look as an example like the word
therefore is going to show up in Tolkien
a lot right if someone uses the word
therefore on Twitter they have a real
message to get out there to you like
they mean something when they say
therefore Twitter just uses it or Toki
and just uses it because it's a filler
word so those those differences are
important and you can't expect your
pipelines to necessarily work across
that so instead of choosing to to take
one pipeline and really dig down deep
into learning it what we're gonna do
instead is we're going to look at how
can we take sort of the really flexible
tools that NLT K and scikit-learn give
us and try to make that something that
is usable because I don't have to make a
ton of choices well I do but when I make
them it kind of does it for me so the
way that I've done this for a lot of my
life is like this and if this doesn't
make you sad you've never done an MLP
project so what what I did would it
would be like hey I'm going to apply
this thing to this text and I'm going to
store this here cool now I'm going to
apply this thing to this text and store
this here well now I'm going to take the
output of this thing and put it through
all of the different tokenizer x' that i
have and i'm going to store those and by
the end i've got 65 different variables
storing 65 different solutions to one
problem and it's a mess so eventually
after probably a year of doing this
which is sort of indefensible on my part
I decided that maybe I should try to
come up with a more useful way to
approach this problem and so what I'm
going to present now is a naive but
workable solution to this problem with
the large caveat that I know this is not
the best solution but it does inform how
we might think about these solutions
going forward so what do we actually
need from our solution so when I when I
kind of laid this problem out
that we kind of want to be able to try
all of the different things because
depending on our data set different
things are going to work better so
instead of just picking one what I want
to be able to do is pick a set of
choices plug them into some some API
somewhere and then never have to think
about it again until I look at what the
behavior is I don't care about the
internal workings of how this piece
talked to this piece I want to write
that one time abstract that away so I
can actually think about what the
pipeline is doing and so that's what
we're gonna try to build so with that
sort of in mind let me walk through the
sort of the code with the note that the
code really doesn't matter here like I'm
using this as a backdrop for how we're
thinking about the code the data flow
don't worry if it doesn't necessarily
make sense or don't get like lost and
trying to read it so what we're going to
do is we're basically going to create a
class that's going to hold all of the
data flow for us we don't care what
pieces get slotted in we just want it to
handle the data going from one end to
the other and so I might do something
like hey let me put in a nice little
vectorizer here let me hand off a
tokenizer let me hand off a cleaner let
me hand off a stemmer and when I hand
those off to you I want you to just know
what to do with them and continue to
pass those down the chain as you go so
in order to sort of manage that what
we're going to do is we're going to
store all of these pieces as attributes
inside of our data pipeline piece okay
and then what we can do is we can
provide like sort of baseline things
where the data comes in and the data
always comes out it's sort of a
functional style of programming here so
other than the fact that we're storing
these pieces that the actual data flow
is just going to be top to bottom and
then let's look at the output so I might
have some very simple tokenizer here
that just splits on spaces it doesn't do
anything smart but I could also have a
different example where I pass in a
tokenizer that says you know what do
something smart break down contractions
break down anything that you want all
that I care about is that when I hand
you the text you return to me the text
split into pieces the way that you want
to do it
okay so our pipeline isn't necessarily
going to be something where we like
where we need to control everything the
only thing we really need to control is
that when we're doing our NLP we just
need to make sure that the pieces talk
together and as long as we're sort of
conscientious about that that can come
out the next step might be something
like a base cleaning of the text so
maybe I say you know what give me my
text I'm going to tokenize it I'm going
to lowercase it I'm going to stem it I'm
going to do all these other things with
it and then when I'm done I'm just going
to pass that back out so that whatever
flow I have it's always continuing down
low down that down the waterfall and
then sort of the key piece is that we're
going to extract to abstract away all of
the challenges of maintaining everything
okay so what we're going to do then is
basically just write some kind of I'm
stealing this this API from SK learn
because they're smarter than me so I'm
just going to say you know what whatever
my pipeline is doing when I say fit I
want you to go ahead and run through and
do all of this I want you to clean
things I want you to learn from the data
what you need to learn I need want you
to learn the pre-processing I want you
to do whatever you need to do to make
sure that when I later ask you to clean
up my documents I can say hey go clean
and it just spits back a document that's
clean okay so that comes out of my fit
function and then my transform function
down here is basically the the other
side of that piece which is when I get
ready to use you I don't want to have to
think about what you're what to do I
just want to say do the thing right so
this is again abstracting away all of
that messiness and saying do the thing
and so what using this looks like now is
instead of that mess that I started with
which was like 25 lines of measuring
things and keeping track of them is now
I just say hey I would like to
pre-process please learn from my corpus
now tell me what you learned
okay so there's three lines of code
hiding all of these different choices
because I can slot in a porter stemmer
or a Lancaster steamer or whatever limit
Iser I want as long as I slot them in
carefully so basically what we've
accomplished so far is we've given our
piece
nice house to live in right like I've
got all these these choices that I'm
making and all this really does is say
cool here's a bucket nice bucket right
and now that bucket says when I say fit
or transform it does everything the
bucket but it doesn't really take away a
lot of the challenge which is this
alright I still if I want to try 25
different pipelines I've still got 25
different variables floating around so
I've made my my problem look a little
bit nicer but I haven't really solved my
problem yet because it still falls to
the user to keep track of everything
that's happening which is what we were
trying to fix in the first place so
there's sort of a next step which is
what if I make this something that is
basically transient okay so I don't want
to store in memory all of these
different pipelines and manage them what
I can do instead is set up each pipeline
and then throw it out to a file until
I'm ready to use it right so now these
pipelines become individual pieces that
can be picked up and slotted in wherever
I want them to go so it's it's I mean
it's essentially docker containers but
for weaklings like myself that can't
handle docker containers yet right so
like this becomes just if I can save all
of those pieces and in their Train state
all I have to do is load the piece that
I want run things through it and then
take it back out of out of play and so
what this does is it basically opens
that up to me so it goes through and it
says you know what
whenever you figure out what you want to
do like let's say I'm trying 25
different pipelines I'm gonna construct
that pipeline I'm gonna initialize it
and then I'm just gonna dump it to file
and then I'm going to give myself an
option to load it back from file okay so
then what that allows me to do is
something that looks like this so these
are the kind of the two parts of
managing your pipelines if you're
thinking about it in this way one is you
construct all of the pipelines and you
just dump them to file and then whatever
you're ready to use them all you have to
do is say look up every pipeline that
I've ever created and now go do the
transformation with them okay so now
instead of having all of this mess of
files to keep track of and memory to
manage and things like that
everything is just dumped to my hard
drive and then as I load I can load the
pieces as I want them
and do whatever I want with them so I
can load if I've got 25 models I'm gonna
load 25 models and then pull data out of
it and see how it does okay so that's
the pre-processing side of things that
leads us to sort of the next step which
is now let's actually use this to solve
a problem and what that what this does
for us is it basically takes us back to
non NLP machine learning so I think a
lot of us that got into NLP sort of late
in the game understand the machine
learning side of things way better than
the NLP side of things at least that's
true for myself and so if I can get to a
point where I'm doing the machine
learning side of things without having
to think about the NLP so much that
becomes a very valuable thing because
that makes me way more efficient and so
that's sort of what this does which is
it basically says you know what maybe
you will just make this this model wrap
around the pre processing pipeline so I
hand you whatever model I want to run
naive Bayes SVC whatever tuning I need
to do whatever cross-validation all of
that just wraps around this
pre-processing pipeline and I can just
say go write and so I can do all of my
normal stuff that I would do with a non
non NLP project but all of that's kind
of a like made possible by this this
pipeline that I've built and so I can
take this model I can take the create a
pipeline I can slot in whatever pieces I
want from my pipeline and then it's just
back to SK learn again and stealing
their brilliance by saying you know what
fit transform fit and then down here fit
transform predict so by thinking about
how we're stacking our pre-processing
stuff together we're now basically
taking a lot of the onus off of the user
or in this case myself so that I don't
have as many chances to screw things up
is basically what it comes down to I can
say at the top build 25 different
pipelines do 25 different ways of
feature extraction I don't really care
what what they are once I've made some
choices about them but I want you to try
as many as possible and then once I'm
down here I can start doing things like
looking at the score looking at the
behavior I can look at measure accuracy
I can look at whatever metrics I care
about that are at the end of the
pipeline without having to man
the top end of the pipeline so much so
basically there's sort of three major
takeaways that that I would argue that
you can come from this and let's say for
one of which is don't do it the way that
I just did it like do it in a much
better way make your code way cleaner
than I will ever make my code because
I'm lazy
but the other three are NLP does some
really neat things but I think everyone
that's ever done it acknowledges that
the process is messy and terrible like
even if you think it's a glorious
invention at some point you have been
swearing at your computer at 3:00 in the
morning threatening to throw it out a
window if you're doing an LP and so with
some planning it's possible to organize
things into a consistent flow and that's
that that idea of pipelines and
pipelines often get applied to like
enterprise data right like I'm I'm
working for a bank I've got data flowing
in and I've got this pipeline to manage
it and take it and do things we often
forget to apply that back to NLP we have
often forget too that you know what
maybe if I take some time and organize
how my data flows it's going to save me
hassle down the road and then
abstracting away a lot of that mess is
also a very powerful tool because if I'm
not worrying if I'm not spending all of
my brainpower on managing the pipeline
but I'm instead letting the code manage
the pipeline for me then all of a sudden
I can really dive into the parts where
I'm better suited to solve those
problems and so taking the time to think
about your data pipeline putting it into
action and making it abstract away the
the handling parts I think is something
that I haven't seen applied to NLP as
much and we really should be as a
community starting to do that more and
with that thank you very much and I'll
take some questions
any questions
when you persist the pipeline's two-disc
do you persist like a trained version of
your vectorizer Zoar I mean ideally
you'd want to leave that untrained for
each new data set that you're passing
through right because everything else is
deterministic but that particular piece
depends on your data set right right so
I think in this case whenever I
persisted data it's after doing a fit
because I want to just load the pipeline
directly into transformation so later I
don't have to relearn anything but the
choice there is really about like where
where do you do your fitting in your
pipeline are you are you persisting this
and then applying it to a bunch of data
sets or are you learning once persisting
it and then only using it at the end to
make your you know to make the
predictions or whatever you're doing so
I think either way could good work just
fine more questions
thank you really interesting I like that
just make sure that I kind of caught the
intent it sounds like the way that
you've optimized it you know machine
learning folks we also do hyper
parameter optimization but it seems like
here that can be expanded out and some
of the pre-code of pipelines this the
process the different choices can also
be part of just a hands-off optimization
regime did I understand that correctly
yeah
so basically I looked at
cross-validation and thought wow that's
really nice I wish I could do that with
all of the pieces of like all the
different token ideas that I can try and
see what works for my data and so that
was basically the idea was just you know
at some point we need to and maybe
somebody else's like has done this way
better than I have but you know we need
to make that like grid search ideology
of let's optimize on what we have apply
to both pre-processing and the modeling
not just the modeling anyone else
all right thank you thank you
[Applause]
you